le premier ministre du québec a lancé un
appel en faveur de l'achat local et de
la production agroalimentaire local
également concrètement que faut-il faire
pour atteindre cet objectif
jean martin fortier directeur de la
production maraîchère à la ferme des
quatre temps auteur du jardiniers
maraîchers coauteur de l'avenir et dans
chambon soir jean martin fortier
vous êtes dans votre sert à ce que je
comprends bien vous êtes à saint-armand
n'est ce pas oui au jardin de la
grelinette danseurs de la pépinière de
tomates et unis la journée et vous
finissez la journée et à la ferme des
quatre temps quitte à hemmingford vous
me disiez avant d'entrer en entrevue
qu'elle est en quarantaine présentement
c'est ça pour pouvoir poursuivre les
opérations qu'on était un plus gros
groupe launay 10 10 ouvriers agricoles
dans le maraîchage on a on appelait
mesure que tout le monde puisse rester
vivent ensemble en unité c'est c'est
souvent des jeunes sont un peu à leurs
premiers pas dans la culture donc c'est
un peu l'aventuré pourrait donc ils ont
relevé le défi mais nous on veut l'on
veut produire le plus qu'on peut parce
que on a l'intuition que je pense que
les produits maraîchers vont être en
demande cet été quand françois legault
dit je veux plus de production le cas je
vois ça augmenté la semaine passée il en
a parlé à plusieurs reprises
qu'est ce qui doit se passer selon vous
pour augmenter pour que ça devienne
réalité que cette production locale
augmente mon idée que j'ai soumis j'ai
publié une lettre ouverte dans la presse
ce matin c'est la suivante c'est une
idée que ça fait longtemps que j'étudie
c'est de dire si hydro québec pouvait
avoir un tarif préférentiel pour la
production légumière cancer pour les
petits maraîchers
je crois que ça pourrait absolument
changer changer ce qui est possible en
terme de ti quand on parle du nord
district de rigueur fillon on a toujours
l'impression qu'au québec à cause de
l'hiver on peut pas produire mais c'est
faux parce qu'on a une lumière quand on
est dans des abris on est capable de
faire des cultures à partir du mois de
janvier février mars mais les coûts de
chauffage
l'aspect non durables de chauffer avec
du fuel ou dugald le profane fait en
sorte que ça ne me limite beaucoup mais
si c'était de l'hydro électricité
renouvelable
en plus si elle était
vraiment pas cher pour les maraîchers
puisse vraiment opéré et l'on sera
capable d'ouvrir toute nouvelle unité de
production prévu que les petites fermes
sont déjà établis à travers les paniers
bio puis les marchés un peu partout sur
le territoire du québec telles idées ça
serait juste de rendre cette énergie là
à ses produits par là pour qu'ils
puissent conduire sur de longues
périodes de temps dans leur propre
saisonnalité la nouvelle pdg
d'hydro-québec sophie brochu à parler
justement d'autonomie alimentaire en fin
de semaine à tout le monde en parle ça
vous dit quoi d'entendre ces propos là
est ce que vous lui avez parlé j'ai pas
parlé directement j'ai parlé avec le
ministre la culture j'ai parlé avec
différents intervenants donc c'est
vraiment une idée qui est en vie en ce
moment moi je pense que c'est une bonne
idée surtout quand quand on pose sur un
peu la réflexion on comprend que
présentement il ya beaucoup
d'hydroélectricité qui est pas vendu aux
états unis donc qui est juste qui dort
qui sert à rien donc c'est même pas
c'est même pas une dépense de la
cheminée dans d'autres projets donc
c'est sûr qu'il vaut il va falloir qu
hydro fasse les bons choix madame brochu
je pense qu'elle est bien au courant de
la crise qu'on va vivre cet été et moi
je soumets l'idée parce que je fais de
l'agriculture à l'année depuis longtemps
dans des cercles sont chauffés
minimalement puis j'ai vu le potentiel
je connais les principes
j'ai assez d'expérience plus de pratique
j'ai assez voyagé dans le monde pour
voir ce qui est possible
je pense qu'au québec ça serait de se
donner un outil concret 5
c'est pas compliqué on n'a pas besoin de
réinventer rien on fait juste rendre un
approvisionnement d'hydroélectricité
disponible à l'adie milliers de petits
maraîchers qui vont pouvoir avoir des
plus gros volumes de production dès
janvier février mars avril et l'étendue
s'est passé quand vous parlez de crise
qu'on va vivre cet été
image et ça qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement c'est moi je veux pas être le
prophète de malheur c'est pas ça c'est
que si je crois que je crois que les
nations unies viennent d'annoncer qu'ils
avaient il y aurait probablement dit
pénurie parce que si le réflexe
dans différents pays notamment aux états
unis c'est de fermer leurs frontières
pour pouvoir assurer l'approvisionnement
dans leur propre pays et ainsi qu'au
québec plus de 40% le biais des légumes
qu'on retrouve en épicerie viennent des
états unis
donc ce facteur là avec l'autre facteur
qui est dans les cas de vent dans les
grosses fermes mécaniser la récolte elle
est quand même manuel
donc si les ouvriers commencent à tomber
malade si ça prend quelques semaines
avant que la chaîne d'approvisionnement
des barques près de chez moi donc tu
sais tu pas utopiste c'est pas
improbable de penser qu'ils pourraient
avoir des trous d'approvisionnement dès
les prochaines semaines et donc si on
sait d'où la réflexion d'avoir une
agriculture qui est qui et qui est
souveraine et là ils seront localisés
est-ce qu'on peut jean martin fortier
agir rapidement maintenant mois d'avril
pour combler les trous de
provisionnement des prochains mois à
court terme c'est sûr que le citoyen lui
peut s'engager auprès du réseau des
fermiers de famille par exemple les
réseaux fermés famille points or depuis
déjà rentrer en relation contact avec un
fermier de famille qui va leur garantir
un approvisionnement
ça c'est des solutions qui vont
fonctionner les marchés fermiers pour
l'été je sais pas on vendait ou avec les
nouvelles mesures de salubrité
mais c'est sûr qu'à moyen et à long
terme il ya une réflexion à avoir sur
comment organiser notre culture au
québec pour qu'en temps de crise du
moins on a une certaine pérennité
qu'on soit capable de faire face à ces
crises 9 les réponses sont beaucoup
moins compliqué que peut-être dans
d'autres secteurs parce que notre
agriculture elle est déjà là elle est
déjà vivante elle est bien soutenu mais
maintenant redouté est un frein je pense
que l'hydro électrique pourrait être la
solution pays vous parlez aussi dans
votre texte dans la presse matin vous
évoquez une transformation du système
agricole avec une décentralisation de la
chaîne de production ça implique quoi en
fait je pense qu'il faut que les
ressources qui sont mises par exemple
les politiques d'achat au gouvernement
ce soin d'éviter d'avoir souvent ce
qu'on cherche c'est d'abord juste une
centrale pour pour les grosses
approvisionnement donc sa salle a poussé
depuis les 30 dernières années les
fermes a toujours augmenté en volume de
production pour être capable
d'approvisionner soit les épiceries ou
soit les hôpitaux mais il faut revoir le
système pour que toutes ces chaînes là
puissent s'approvisionner à une
multitude de plus petits produits par
des lois c'est une réflexion que
d'autres pays ont fait notamment en
suède et au danemark avec beaucoup de
succès
je crois que le québec avec la volonté
qu'on a aujourd'hui de s'approvisionner
localement nous sourire avec les
produits du québec on de tout est en
place pour qu'on soit capables de faire
que cette décentralisation là qui à mon
avis est l'avis de plusieurs le et et
l'avenue si on veut avoir une culture
brésilien la crise actuelle est inquiète
catalyseur pour ça selon vous mais je
crois que oui je crois que la crise
qu'elle nous permet de constater c'est
l'importance d'un geste fondamental qui
est de manger et que si on a des
problèmes d'approvisionnement ce niveau
là mais là on est vraiment des gros
problèmes bien fille mois
voila voila je crois qu'on n'entame la
solution en ce moment jean martin
fortier
merci beaucoup je suis convaincu votre
message très attendu
merci et à la prochaine merci bonne
soirée